get up the holiday everybody's kind of
still here even the fans don't believe
that this is happening but the floater
sputters down tree
timeout San Antonio ready to play second
hook yes yes plain and simple
and they now and this is the byproduct
will put it in play Chicago has one
timeout remaining the Spurs at one
timeout remaining
right now with our got to get up the
pressure no one's gonna take a shot too
early in the clock on the shot clock for
done barking it with the scram
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
eight seconds to go Spurs take their
final time but you can see our guys
weren't even switching their they knew
that if Patty Mills switches on Laurie
market and they're throwing market in
the ball and he's got a mismatch Patty
Mills goes underneath the screen to stay
with done but done just had that type of
half that terrific second half and every
time he scored in these situations he's
turning around he's barking maybe at the
Spurs better job and every time he
scored in these situations he's turning
around
he's bargains maybe at the Spurs pitcher
Joe talking himself up
[Music]